[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
prosecutors will seek the death penalty
for chad day bell if convicted in the
murders of two children
and his wife how this impacts the
upcoming trial of one of the doomsday
duo defendants
and a judge rules r kelly's illegal
marriage to singer aliyah
can be used against him as evidence in
his sex trafficking trial
the shocking allegations ahead of jury
selection plus
the man accused of fatally shooting at
tick tock star and his friend in a movie
theater appears in court
what the suspect is now saying in a
jailhouse interview and
a criminal complaint is filed against
new york's governor andrew cuomo
the allegations of groping and physical
touching being called the most egregious
against the governor
cuomo's attorneys now responding this
investigation
was conducted in a manner to support a
pre-determined
narrative law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer co-host terry austin
is off
we begin with a major legal development
in the doomsday cult couple saga
prosecutors have announced they are now
seeking the death penalty for chad dabo
prosecutors in fremont county idaho
filed their notice to seek the death
penalty against daebel on thursday
day bell is facing eight charges in
connection to the murder of his first
wife
tammy debell along with the murders of
j.j valo and tyler ryan the children of
his current wife
laurie valodebel lori is also charged in
the murders but is deemed incompetent to
stand trial for now
investigators have said the couple was
preparing for an end of the world
scenario and wanted to rid the world of
zombies and the human bodies they
inhabit
according to court documents the murders
are especially heinous and the defendant
exhibited utter disregard for human life
daebel's trial is set to begin in
november
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor nima romani now nima
the death penalty is being asked for
citing daebel's cruelty disregard for
human life
and danger to society but also he
committed this for some sort of uh
monetary gain
thoughts on the death penalty and the
reasons
ryan if you believe in the death penalty
this is a death penalty case
what is more cruel and heinous than
killing your own children and burying
them in your backyard
clearly utter disregard for human life
and let's talk about the propensity i
mean everyone that comes near this
doomsday cold couple
ends up dead so regardless of what side
you're on
idaho is a death penalty case and this
is a case
that merits it and the evidence is
overwhelming frankly
the only question is what took
prosecutors so long
to charge these two and announce the
death penalty they really pushed it till
almost the last minute yeah so i'm
guessing you're not surprised in any way
shape or form this is what you expected
absolutely there's no question the only
surprise was that it took so long to
charge them with the murders
and now announce that they're seeking
the death penalty this case does merit
it at least for chat
so that makes sense and don't forget
he's also being prosecuted for the death
of his wife so what those three i would
agree with you if you
aren't supporting the death penalty this
would be the type of case turning now
to california where a man accused of
killing a tick-tock star
and his friend appears in court after
granting a jailhouse interview
law and crime's anginate levy is here
with what this defendant told a reporter
anjanette brian a newspaper
quotes joseph jimenez is saying that he
was diagnosed with schizophrenia
eight months ago and never refilled his
prescription for his medication
right now there is no indication that he
knew either one of the people he is
accused
of killing joseph jimenez appearing in a
california courtroom with his attorneys
who were
less than pleased that a reporter
interviewed him in jail
the record should reflect that at no
point did
we authorize that approve that agree
with that
in fact we've been very clear about
making no comments to the press or to
anyone in this case
jimenez is accused of shooting tick-tock
influencer
anthony barajas and riley goodrich in a
corona california movie theater that was
nearly empty
last month the riverside press
enterprise quotes jimenez as saying
i wish i didn't do it and the voices
said my friends and family were going to
be killed
goodrich died at the theater but barajas
passed away after being placed on life
support
jimenez faces murder charges with
special circumstances including the fact
that multiple murders were committed
and he's being accused of lying in
weight the defendant
was concealing his purpose concealing
his or her purpose
what they were doing and then waited
and watched and waited before actually
making a surprise attack questions have
also been raised about whether others
could be charged
since three witnesses may have seen him
leave to retrieve the gun
we've charged the accounts in this case
that we believe are best supported by
the evidence
meanwhile jimenez's lawyers were granted
an order that allows mental health
professionals to see him but no one else
unless they approve it they're angry a
reporter was allowed to speak with him
we consider a very gross violation of
his right to counsel
and joseph jimenez is currently being
held without bail he will be arraigned
when he is back in court
in september brian thank you anjan
mima mental health evaluations and
statements made to the press
are you sensing this could be a case
that raises a mental health defense
and also could the statements he made to
the press be used against him
ryan there's no question this is a
mental health case because there's
really no defense on the marriage i mean
these are some very damaging admissions
that ximena's made and
i know his defense attorneys are upset
the last thing you want if your criminal
defense attorney is your client
to say that i did it and say it in a
very public way to the press
but unfortunately for them there is no
defense
that this violated the attorney-client
privilege this wasn't law enforcement
this
wasn't someone who invoked and
ultimately the privilege is the clients
and the client
is free to waive it to the extent that
he or she wants so
i understand why they're not happy but
there is no legal recourse here
yeah there seems to be no privilege and
also i don't see how the fifth amendment
may apply here either so those words may
come in
and jeanette could the defendant face
the death penalty
you know he could brian but a
spokesperson for the district attorney
said that decision has not yet been made
because there are these special
circumstances surrounding surrounding
both of the murder charges
he could face the death penalty these
charges are eligible for it but as we
all know
california currently has a moratorium on
the death penalty so we'll just have to
wait and see
what the d.a decides absolutely so with
that
that uh moratorium on the death penalty
anjanet so it'll be like all the other
cases we've seen where
if they seek it it may not be executed
for lack of a par
a better word uh if he is found guilty
right
yeah exactly right brian we've seen that
in california where
people are sentenced to death and it
isn't carried out
and there are years and years of appeals
of course but if there's a new governor
you never know there could be a new
policy
all right we'll keep eyes on that case
as it progresses thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily a
criminal complaint now filed against new
york's governor
how his attorneys are responding but
first the start of r kelly's trial is
right around the corner
how prosecutors are now able to tell the
jury about his marriage to beloved
singer aaliyah when she was just 15
years old
find out after the break
[Music]
welcome back jury selection r kelly's
new york trial is scheduled to begin
next week and now prosecutors will be
allowed to present evidence of the r
bean sager's secret marriage to aliyah
the hit song by aaliyah debuted in 1994.
it was produced by r
kelly and just months later the two
married but
aaliyah was just 15 years old and
federal prosecutors in new york accused
kelly of bribing an illinois
government employee to obtain a fake id
for aaliyah
according to court records that fake id
was used to obtain a marriage license
listing her age as 18. aaliyah died in
2001 in a plane crash
she was just 22 years old prosecutors in
new york are now calling her jane dome
number one
this week a judge ruled that evidence
showing kelly had sexual contact with
leah
when she was a teenager can be presented
to the jury prosecutors alleged aliyah
became pregnant and as a result
in an effort to shield himself from
criminal charges related to his illegal
sexual relationship with jane done
number one
kelly arranged a secret marriage to
prevent her from being compelled to
testify
against him in the future kelly is
facing charges of transporting underage
girls across state lines
for sexual activity and child
pornography he's plead
not guilty let's bring back former
federal prosecutor nima romani
nemo r kelly's marriage to aliyah has
been whispered for decades
how do you see kelly's relationship to
now jane doe number one
being used against him in a trial almost
20 years after her death
brian prosecutors love this type of 404b
or other prior badass evidence because
it helps dirty up the defendant let's
not forget that r kelly was acquitted
back in 2008 the last time he was tried
so the more that you can present this
evidence to the jury helps dirty up the
defendant
we saw the same tactic used both against
bill cosby and harvey weinstein
so that's the what and that makes sense
but as you know it's one thing to know
something it's another thing to prove it
in court do you see any difficulties the
prosecution may face
in this alleged rape from 1994
even the district judge in this case
asked
r kelly's defense attorneys do you
dispute that sexual contact occurred
when you were married to a 15 year old
i think the jury is going to see right
through that argument if r kelly's
counsel gets
up there and says we were married but
nothing of a sexual nature happened i
don't think that's a particularly good
argument although one i expect them to
make yeah i mean
they've got the marriage license they've
got the name they've got it listed as 18
at the time
that's pretty damning evidence you think
it's a non-credible argument to say
hey we got married we just slept in
separate beds the entire time
that's not gonna fly i don't think so i
don't think the jury's gonna buy the
ricky lucy argument with two twin beds
especially when it comes to r kelly i
think the more this type of evidence
that comes in related to other victims
that is what's going to help the feds
finally convict him
well he did write i believe that i
believe i can fly i'm not sure if that
argument is going to work here but
we'll keep eyes on this case as it
begins just around the corner
two police officers and bystanders who
rescued a baby pinned under a car in
yonkers new york
are recognized for their quick action
law and crime's angina levy is back with
the ceremony to recognize those involved
in the rescue
you know brian it's been about two weeks
since that eight-month-old baby girl and
her mother were hit by a suspected drunk
driver
now you may recall surveillance video
and also police body camera video
captured those horrific tense moments
when both of them were hit
they were crossing the street in wrong
yonkers rather when
the vehicle crossed the road and smashed
them into a storefront
officers rocco fusco and paul semayendi
were getting breakfast nearby and heard
the crash
the officers and three men lifted the
car off of the baby and her mother
this week the city of yonkers recognized
them for their efforts and the baby's
father
and the wife of the woman hit became
very emotional when he
showed up at the ceremony and thanked
everyone involved in spanish for their
efforts
the police commissioner also spoke at
the ceremony
it's really a recognition and
acknowledgement
of the collaborative effort that they
did together
and i just want to again echo the
mayor's senators about officer samayani
officer fusco
and then our civilians too michael russo
bar castillo
and jose suero um all five who worked
together
and made sure that they literally saved
the life of leslie
the little girl and mother myrna
now the mother and the daughter who were
rescued they are still
in the hospital but their conditions are
improving
according to the husband and father and
the police commissioner
and the man who hit them faces several
charges at this point
brian thank you man well deserved
recognition by all five and we wish a
speedy recovery
to both the mother and that young child
coming up on law and crime daily why one
woman is speaking with a sheriff's
office over groping allegations by
governor cuomo
plus the shocking news that brings
robert durst's trial to a halt
for now why there's a pause in the trial
of the relay state air accused of murder
next
[Music]
welcome back long crimes jesse weber is
covering the heartbreaking death
of a four-month-old boy and the
conviction of his mother on the latest
episode of his show
prime crime
hey there brian yeah we've covered the
deaths of young children before but the
manner in which sterling keane
died and the condition he was left in
never seen anything like that
now the focus would turn on the parents
and we learned a lot especially when the
mother
cheyenne harris spoke with law
enforcement
do you remember putting stripping in the
swing
[Music]
also we're going to get into when the
father zachary keene took the stand
and we sit down with the investigator
and some of the lawyers
from this case tune in to law and crime
it's never okay to drink and drive and
it's definitely never okay
to drink and drive then crash into a
government building
dan abrams law and crime founder and
host of the a e series court camp
is here to tell us about one man who
didn't get the message
next we head to the burke county
courthouse in morganton north carolina
or more accurately
the lobby of the courthouse
that's herbert bristol getting out of
his car
naturally after parking his car in a
courthouse
he puts on his hazard lights here it is
from another angle
[Applause]
bristol who'd been drinking before the
incident just
crashed his car through the entrance of
the building
no sense of urgency here
bristol just gets out of his parked car
in the lobby of a federal building
lights a cigarette and begins to walk
out
yes he's leaving the same way he came in
this time without his car
ironically police believe bristol was
already scheduled for a court appearance
on drunk driving charges
thanks to this incident there would be
another court appearance for bristol
on a litany of charges including failure
to report an accident
despite all the charges that surely
awaited him
bristol didn't seem too concerned
seems like he was just parking in the
wrong spot and got to court a little
early
when we come back an appeals court
issues their decision on the conviction
of ex-cop anger
amber geiger for the murder of both jean
will the jury's guilty verdict be upheld
or
overturned find out after the break
[Music]
welcome back a texas court of appeals is
upholding the conviction of former
dallas police officer amber geiger for
murdering botham jean in his apartment
a panel of three judges ruled there was
sufficient evidence to convict geiger of
murder
she's now serving a 10-year sentence
geiger testified at trial that she
accidentally entered jean's apartment
thinking it was her own prosecutors
argued geiger drew her service weapon
intending to shoot john dead an attorney
for john's family says they're relieved
by the court's decision
but not shocked a tennessee jury has
found stephen wiggins guilty of fatally
shooting a sheriff's deputy and lighting
his body on fire wickets admitted to
shooting dickinson county sheriff's
sergeant
daniel baker in may 2018. a jury
convicted wiggins of all charges
including murder
arson and impersonating a police officer
the same jury will now hear evidence and
recommend to the judge
if wiccans should face the death penalty
or spend the rest of his life in prison
testimony the penalty phase begins on
saturday
and the trial of robert durst abruptly
came to a halt on thursday
we're now learning that's because a
member of the public inside the
courtroom
has tested positive for covet 19.
testimony is on hold until at least
monday morning
durst is on trial for the murder of his
best friend susan berman
in december 2000. prosecutors have
rested and the defense's memory expert
was on the stand
dr elizabeth loftos was in the middle of
day two of a contentious cross
examination
by prosecutor john lewin
now to a major update in the probe into
new york's governor andrew
cuomo a woman who says cuomo groped her
in the executive mansion has filed a
criminal complaint with the albany
county sheriff
the new york post first reported friday
a woman identified
as executive assistant number one is
following the criminal complaint
according to a report by new york's
attorney general's office executive
assistant one
told investigators the governor grabbed
her rear end when asking her to take a
selfie
the report said the governor denied
touching her backside independent
investigators spoke with 11 women
the ag's office described the
assistant's incident as the most
egregious allegations of physical
touching
cuomo's attorneys held a press
conference on friday to deny all
allegations
but it didn't go exactly as planned
this investigation was conducted in a
manner
to support a pre-determined narrative
am i frozen
okay good afternoon
i apologize in advance for the technical
or actually i apologize after the fact
for the technical difficulties
our ethernet went down me and my team
went through the emails for that day
all the entrance and exit records and
this woman's story which is stated as
fact in the report is false
the documentary evidence does not
support
what she said
and what is disturbing to me is that the
two investigators
did not show that evidence to you
they ignored it
ask them why nema why is executive
assistant one filing complaint bringing
cuomo closer to charges
albany already had the ag's report
brian another day and more bad news for
the current governor maybe soon to be
former governor this is important
because sexual assault is one of the
most underreported crimes as a
prosecutor
rarely do you have victims who are ready
willing and
able to come forward and assist with the
criminal prosecution now that
executive assistant one has made it
clear that she wants to proceed it's
going to make
the district attorney of albany's case
that much stronger
now nima what do you think about the
defense so far for the governor and how
they laid out this timeline
saying this all doesn't make sense well
you have 11 victims here and the folks
who conducted the investigation one of
them is a former federal prosecutor and
the other is a civil employment attorney
let's not forget these were employees so
i'm not surprised that the governor's
defense team has come out and denied
all these accusations but what's more
believable what's more credible that 11
victims
have come forward and they're all lying
or it's the governor who's denying any
responsibility for his conduct
and let's not forget the reason that
executive assistant one came forward
is because she was upset that the
governor
and his defense attorneys have come out
and flat out denied
any of this conduct so nema
intentionally touching a person for no
reason but to dis
to degrade abuse or for sexual
gratification by my read
that's the state law cuomo could have
broken what do you think
i agree brian and you're certainly
you're the expert on new york law being
out there but
grabbing someone's buttocks forcibly
groping their breasts
kissing them on the lips that seems to
fall squarely within the four corners
of the sexual assault law that you just
identified
yeah you better believe that albany is
going to be looking at that
and other charges that they could
potentially press forward against the
governor
here to see whether or not any of these
chargeables stick nema thank you as
always for joining us here today and
giving us that expert analysis
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you